we're going to turn now to the president
of the violence project that's Jillian
Peterson she's a forensic psychologist
and professor of criminology and
criminal justice and also also the
co-author of the violence project how to
stop a mass shooting epidemic uh good
morning thank you very much for being
here Jillian uh how to stop it we'd all
like to know the answer to that and I
think it begins with understanding the
why every time there's a mass shooting
in America and they happen all too often
we ask ourselves why what's the
explanation everything is particular but
are there generalities how do you answer
that question of why
yeah we study cases where perpetrators
have killed four or more people in a
public setting going back to 1966 we've
built a database we've interviewed
perpetrators and the people who knew
them to try to understand what this
Pathway to violence looks like so that
we can stop it and we do see this common
pathway typically involving a chaotic
Early Childhood with violence in the
home developing into a crisis point
where the perpetrator's behavior is
changing and school mass shootings in
particular over 90 percent of
perpetrators tell other people that
they're planning to do this they're
suicidal this tends to be designed as a
final Act they study other perpetrators
that came before them and then of course
they have the ability to get their hands
on the weapons that they need to carry
this out
you know Jillian we heard earlier from
the chief of police in Nashville who
told us that this shooter targeted
children in this school also targeted
the staff might have sought out the head
of the school intentionally what stands
out to you when you hear what we know so
far about this shooting in Nashville
you know
harget
location and the people that represent
their grievance with the world so we see
that perpetrators often kind of hate
themselves often have previous suicide
attempts and then they pick somebody
that they blame for how they're feeling
and so School shooters tend to blame
schools we know that former students are
the most common type of perpetrator to
Target a former Elementary School and
typically they have some sort of
grievance with something that happened
at that school but we'll have to see as
more information emerges if that's the
case here Hey Jillian Nate here you say
it's important not to give the
perpetrators too much attention you
don't even use their names in your book
but here in America for some reason
we're fascinated by who the person is we
want to know their age their race their
gender where they're from all of these
long list of things before we even get
to the actual shooting itself but why is
it important to focus on the why and not
just the who
you know these are designed to be public
spectacles perpetrators are looking for
fame and notoriety they leave these
manifestos behind to get their message
of anger and hate out to the world and
so we all are the people that consume
this we are the spectators of this
horrific violence and their goal is to
make the history books their goal is to
inspire other Shooters behind them to be
known for this in a way that they
weren't known in life so the more that
we can do to starve perpetrators of that
attention that helps stop the social
contagion and doesn't give perpetrators
that Fame that they're seeking and I
want to follow up to Nate's question
because I struggle with this every time
this story happens should we cover it
how should we cover it do you think that
by us covering it are we giving people
ideas I'm always in a quandary about
what is the right thing to do here I
don't want us to become desensitized to
it I think people need to know about it
but is it wrong to continue to cover it
what where do you stand on that
I don't know what to do it's a good
question yeah it's really hard to know
exactly how to approach this in our work
we do tell the Deep stories of where
these perpetrators come from it's
important to understand these Pathways
to violence if we're going to ever stop
this from happening at the same time we
don't need to give the perpetrator the
attention they're seeking by showing
their names showing their face spreading
their Manifesto the more we can focus on
the victims and the heroes I think the
better
all right Jillian Peterson uh thank you
very much we appreciate